en el vídeo anterior vimos la proyección
de fisher de un compuesto que solo tenía
un centro quiral pero esta molécula
tiene dos centros quirales y nuestro
objetivo es determinar la configuración
de esos centros quirales en la
intersección de estas líneas tenemos un
centro quiral y aquí tenemos otro esos
son nuestros dos centros quirales
primero analicemos el de arriba y
asignemos su configuración voy a
dibujarlo por acá sabemos que en la
proyección de fisher las líneas
horizontales representan un enlace que
sale del plano
por ejemplo este enlace de la izquierda
se encuentra hacia nosotros al igual que
este enlace con el h así que del lado
izquierdo tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
nosotros y del lado derecho tenemos 1 h
también hacia nosotros por eso los
representamos con una cuña ahora sabemos
que las líneas verticales en la
proyección de fisher
en un enlace que se aleja de nosotros
esta línea es un enlace que se aleja de
nosotros y lo podemos representar con
una línea punteada y aquí tenemos un
ácido carboxílicos que consiste en un
carbono unido con un doble enlace a un
oxígeno y también está unido a un h ok
ahora vamos con la siguiente línea
vertical esta línea también representa
un enlace que se aleja de nosotros vamos
a dibujar prácticamente estamos viendo
el centro quiral desde arriba y después
este carbono está unido directamente a
un oxígeno un carbono y un hidrógeno
esos son los únicos átomos que
necesitamos para asignar la
configuración ok volvamos a nuestro
centro gira para asignar la
configuración de este centro quiral
necesitamos analizar los átomos que
están unidos directamente a este carbono
vamos
tenemos un hidrógeno un oxígeno y
después tenemos 2 carbonos de todos esos
átomos el oxígeno tiene el número
atómico más grande así que el grupo o h
tiene la prioridad número 1 mientras que
el hidrógeno como tiene el número
atómico más pequeño es el número 4
después tenemos un carbono y un carbono
que tienen el mismo número atómico pero
podemos analizar los átomos a los que se
encuentran unidos directamente por
ejemplo el carbono de abajo está unido
directamente a un oxígeno un carbono y
un hidrógeno que si los acomodamos según
la disminución del número atómico
tenemos oxígeno carbono e hidrógeno
mientras que el carbono de arriba que
pertenece al ácido carboxílicos está
unido con un doble enlace al oxígeno y
eso es como si tuviéramos dos enlaces
con dos oxígenos aunque en realidad
qué es un oxígeno y después tenemos un
enlace con otro oxígeno del lado derecho
así que podemos decir que tenemos
oxígeno oxígeno oxígeno hagamos la
comparación tenemos oxígeno y oxígeno
pero después tenemos oxígeno carbón y
claro el oxígeno gana porque tiene el
número atómico mayor entonces el ácido
carboxílicos tiene la prioridad número 2
y por lo tanto este grupo es el número 3
ahora necesitamos poner el hidrógeno
lejos de nosotros pero voy a usar un
truco que use en el vídeo anterior así
no tenemos que mover la molécula el
truco es ignorar el hidrógeno y solo
tomar en cuenta el grupo 1 2 y 3
entonces si nos movemos del grupo 1 al 2
y al 3 nos movemos en esta dirección es
decir encontrar reloj y en esta
dirección la configuración es
parece ese pero como el hidrógeno se
encuentra hacia nosotros entonces debe
ser lo contrario parecía s pero en
realidad como el hidrógeno se encuentra
hacia nosotros es r en realidad es
entonces si giramos esta molécula para
que el hidrógeno quede lejos de nosotros
veremos que la configuración es r por
eso es más fácil para mí usar el truco
en lugar de mover la molécula ahora
analicemos el otro centro que irá voy a
dibujarlo por acá empecemos con las
líneas horizontales del lado izquierdo
tenemos un enlace con él
y del lado derecho tenemos un enlace con
un hidrógeno así que los dos se
encuentran hacia nosotros y lo h está
del lado izquierdo y tenemos un
hidrógeno del lado derecho ahora vamos
con las líneas verticales esta línea
significa que tenemos un enlace lejos de
nosotros y este es un enlace con un
carbono y este carbono está unido
directamente a un oxígeno un carbono y
un hidrógeno vamos a dibujarlos no
necesitamos poner todos los átomos
porque
sólo queremos asignar la configuración
ahora vamos con la otra línea vertical
aquí tenemos otro enlace que se aleja de
nosotros y se une a este carbón vamos a
dibujar y este carbono está unido
directamente a dos hidrógenos y un
oxígeno dos hidrógenos y un oxígeno
regresemos al centro quiral analicemos
los átomos que están unidos directamente
a este carbono
tenemos un oxígeno un hidrógeno y dos
carbonos sabemos que el oxígeno tiene la
prioridad más alta así que el grupo o h
es el número uno mientras que el
hidrógeno tiene la prioridad más baja
por otro lado tenemos carbono y carbono
pero miren el carbono de arriba está
unido directamente a un oxígeno un
carbono y un hidrógeno así que en orden
decreciente del número atómico
tenemos oxígeno carbono
hidrógeno y el carbono de abajo está
unido a un oxígeno hidrógeno e hidrógeno
oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno vamos a ver
tenemos oxígeno y oxígeno pero después
tenemos carbono hidrógeno claro el
carbono tiene un número atómico mayor
así que el grupo de arriba es el número
2 mientras que el grupo de abajo es el
número 3 nuevamente ignoremos el
hidrógeno y solo tomemos en cuenta el
grupo 1 2 y 3 de 1 a 2 y a 3 nos movemos
en esta dirección que es como las
manecillas del reloj así que parece que
es r
recuerden r es cuando la dirección es
como la de las manecillas del reloj pero
como esta es una proyección de fisher y
el hidrógeno está hacia nosotros el
truco es que la configuración sea
contraria a lo que parece si en este
caso parece que ese r
podemos decir que entre
realidad es ese en realidad es
y listo ya determinamos la configuración
de los dos centros virales este centro
quiral es air air y el carbono de abajo
es ese
practiquemos a dibujar el enantiómero de
este compuesto en el vídeo anterior
pusimos un espejo justo aquí y
reflejamos los grupos por ejemplo este o
h se refleja y después tenemos esto
después tenemos un hidrógeno y ahora
vamos con el hidrógeno de abajo ahí está
después tenemos una línea horizontal y
después tenemos un h aquí tenemos un h
después pongamos la línea vertical y
arriba tenemos un ácido carboxílicos
pero este carbono no es un centro quiral
así que no tenemos que preocuparnos por
reflejarlo podemos escribir c
h y lo mismo ocurre abajo este carbono
no es un centro quiral así que podemos
escribir c h2oh lo más importante es que
si tenemos 1 h del lado derecho
nos quedará de lado izquierdo en la
imagen especular y si tenemos 1
del lado izquierdo en la proyección de
fisher entonces debe estar del lado
derecho en la imagen especular así que
tenemos un par de enantiómero el de la
derecha es la imagen especular o el
reflejo del que tenemos en la izquierda
sin embargo no podemos superponer el de
la derecha sobre el de la izquierda